A recipe for oatmeal cookies
calls for 2 cups of flour for
every 3 cups of oatmeal.
How much flour is needed for a
big batch of cookies that uses
9 cups of oatmeal?
So they tell us that we
have 2 cups of flour.
Let me write that down.
You need 2 cups of flour for
every 3 cups of oatmeal.
Now, what we need to figure
out is how much flour is
needed for a big batch that
uses 9 cups of oatmeal.
We need to figure
out how much.
So let's just call that amount
of flour we need for this
larger batch, let's call it x.
That's equal to x cups of flour
for 9 cups of oatmeal.
All we're saying, look, we need
2 cups of flour for every
3 cups of oatmeal.
That has to be the same
as x for every 9 cups.
The proportion has to hold.
These ratios have to simplify
to the same fraction.
Now, the easiest way to do this,
we can just get rid of
the cups of flour and the cups
of oatmeal for now, and we can
just view this as a simple
proportion problem where it's
2/3 is equal to x/9.
And the simplest way to solve
this is to multiply both sides
of this equation by 9, and the
reason why we're multiplying
by 9 is so it cancels out with
this 9 in the denominator.
You can view it as multiplying
both sides of
the equation by 9/1.
So if you multiply both sides
by 9/1, the left-hand side,
you'll have a 9 in the
numerator, 3 in the
denominator.
You can divide them both by 3.
So 9 divided by 3 is 3.
3 divided by 3 is 1.
So your left side of the
equation is 3 times
2/1, so it's 6/1.
Well, this 9 in the numerator
and this 9 in the denominator,
they cancel out.
They can both be divided by 9.
So they cancel out, so
that is equal to x/1.
6/1 is the same thing as 6. x/1
is the same thing as x.
So we get x is equal to 6.
So we've just figured out, if
the recipe calls for 2 cups of
flour for every 3 cups of
oatmeal, that means that we
need 6 cups of flour for every
9 cups of oatmeal.
So we figured out that
x is equal to 6.